well charlie morton it'll be his seventh
start of the season his third since
coming off of the il christian's hit
everywhere in the lineup hasn't he not
lead off but we've seen him that in
clean up a lot recently now he goes to
the two spot yeah that one hammered by
vasquez
deep drive to left field and it is going
to be out of here a home run for
christian vasquez number five to put the
red sox in front right away against
morton two to nothing well it's been a
while since vasquez have has went bridge
i tell you what he got a breaking ball
the first breaking ball that charlie
throws and it's up in his eyes and he
crushed it well it's almost like he was
looking for that pitch he was right on
it martin perez yeah last time out had a
hard time throwing strikes walk six guys
walk the bases loaded at some point
almost got the win in that game we'll
see what we get
today mike brasso they'll get a shot at
the
left-hander
there's a shot toward the
corner it's going to be out of the reach
of munoz hitting third window he will
score it's going to be a double for
bronzo and the rays get on the board
braso's double
into the right field corner and wait
until you see the location of this pitch
brasso goes and gets it
this ball
is up and away
and a similar pitch to what bronzo swung
and missed at earlier in the at-bat but
this he's going to go and get that ball
ending up off the plate but it was
elevated so he just throws the barrel
out there other times
above that there's a high popper
down the right side near the line rim
throw into foul territory and had to
hurry to make that catch just in front
of the bullpen mound
chavis is out number two
the velocity of charlie morton as we see
a little bit at the end how about that
and then he catches it down below the
belt
maybe he did not see that ball that well
wasn't tracking it but he made the play
nonetheless slowing the game down
let me check my phone
high popper short leveling out and
chavis come again
uh who's going to get this one oh and
nobody it drops
beside lynn and chavis and the rays get
a break there
boy that ball
had a lot of hang time
and
when you saw then keep going out and
chavez continue again
well you're not all together surprised
this happened
two guys way too close to each other you
knew communication issues all around and
that's what happens unfortunately lynn
realizes late
2-2
fly ball lifted left center field
margo's going to be there to make the
catch and that retires the side
they leave three we got to the bottom of
the fourth 2-1 boston
so one away with adamus
at first
now kevin smith
it's kevin smith who lists one in the
air to deep left field over the head of
chavis and over the cardboard cutouts a
long two-round homer for kevin smith his
first is array and the rays have taken
their first lead it's three to two
well kevin must have been paying
attention because perez has been trying
to
sneak very hittable fastballs by guys
early in the count and
he's been trying to just work ahead of
guys right there it wasn't
looked at me like he was maybe trying to
cut it a little bit
and he just didn't cut it enough
and smith was ready and
put a real real good swing on it and
that was a no doubt there's something
about this right here that just makes
you feel like rafi is about to do major
damage just one of those times you have
a little bit of a hunch
fairbanks doing that dance on the mound
the pitch is ripped down the right field
line will it stay fair yes it will it
slams off the wall this will score at
least one run munoz has scored vasquez
comes to third he will hold there it's
an rbi double for devers that just put a
hole in the right field wall it's three
to three in saint pete well that was
scalded we'll check the exit velocity
110 at least don't you think joe that
thing was murdered it was a low curve
probably wasn't a strike
he went down and got it and hammered it
and the o2 pitch to martinez
this guy can throw into the back
screen too
off the third baseman a shortstop adamus
guns and will get him
on the ricochet as the run scores
vazquez is in the red sox lead at four
to three
[Music]
arroyo to climb in he has struck out fly
to center over two
got a pitch to drive he socked that one
to right field that's sailing back there
and that ball is out home run by arroyo
who has homered for the second straight
day
two run blasts that is impressive arroyo
back to back days two run shots this the
opposite field
and he put a i thought he smoked this
ball in the gap i didn't think it was
going to get out but it shows you the
kind of power he has on a line for the
red sox here comes the o2
swag and a miss he got him 95 miles an
hour the red sox win it